[Music]
hi
my name is andrew botran and i'm a data
reporter for the washington post's
investigative team
and i'm here to talk about the opioid
files
and how we investigated pharmaceutical
companies and the government
and made data accessible to all this is
a two-week-year-old boy
in an isolation ward in west virginia
any sound seriously disturbs him and he
won't stop crying
and that's because he was born addicted
to opioids
and he is one among thousands of
children separated from the parents and
families
and forced into state care by an opioid
epidemic that has fractured families
in every corner of the country in west
virginia alone
more than 50 200 lives over the past few
decades
have been lost and we've seen the
effects of this
we know that the number of children in
foster care in west virginia has doubled
ever since the epidemic started
and other effects that we've been able
to see are the death rates
in communities across the country in
west virginia
we could see the effects of the opioid
death rates
and we can also see that there were also
higher rates of child abuse and neglect
claims in those same areas
state officials said that more than 80
of children in foster care
have been affected by the drug epidemic
so we've seen the effects we've never
really been able to see the causes
before
not with a lot of specificity
the thing is pharmaceutical companies
and the drug enforcement administration
have been able to see this for the
longest time
because every single pill from
manufacturer to distributor
to pharmacy is tracked in a data set and
it's called the
automated
reports and consolidated or system
and the drug enforcement administration
is also under the department of justice
and it's fact because prescription pain
pills
are scheduled to drug which means it has
a high potential for abuse
with use potentially leading to severe
psychological and physical dependence
and we call it our ghosts for short
and so pharmaceutical companies and the
government have
known the scope of this data for the
longest time
the reach of the spread of these pills
and journalists and researchers have
tried to get this data set for the
longest time as well
but we've only been able to get it at
the aggregate level maybe by state maybe
by county maybe by zip code
made by overall drug we've never been
able to get it at the raw data set level
where we could really dig into the
nuances of the data
every time we've made a request for it
it's been denied
that is until recently
so for context the most powerful people
in the pharmaceutical america
didn't want to release and a lot of the
most powerful people in the department
of justice didn't want this data
released
however when two thousand communities
across the u.s
and does sued dozens of big drug
companies over the destruction
and that painkillers were causing across
the country
a federal judge ordered that the argos
data set be made available
to those plaintiffs for examination
however he they sailed it away from the
public
and from the media and so the washington
post as well as the
charleston gazette mail sued for access
to that data
and so we appealed the decision
and a group of apple judges ruled that
the protective order on the arcos data
should be amended
in effect they released data from 2006
to 2012 and eventually 2014.
and so we got our hands on other data
the day it was released
and what we found out was that the data
set was huge
it had about 42 columns which isn't too
bad
but it had literally hundreds of
millions of rows of data
for every pain pill order sold between
2006 and eventually 2014.
and so the team of us there were about
three data reporters including myself
we used a mix of different statistical
analyzing languages like
python and r and so in order to
maintain great communication between the
two we used data structures that could
operate between the two languages
such as parquet and feather and because
the datasets were so huge
we use packages like do parallel
in order to handle all that
and in order to exchange our analysis
methodologies
and reports we wrote up everything in
jupiter notebooks or our markdown i also
created a shiny app
so that we could investigate and dig
into pharmacies
that looked uh suspicious because any
way you might have sliced it would raise
a different set of
pharmacies that might have uh set off
some suspicious orders
and so this data set was revelatory
because
it showed where each pill moved from
manufacturer to distributor
to pharmacy for the first time and so we
could see everything both in aggregate
and fine detail and this is what we
found out
we could see that 100 million billion
pills saturated the country between 2006
and 2014 and pharmaceutical companies
from
manufacturers distributors to pharmacies
made billions of dollars a year
and we could finally see the connection
between the deaths from opioids
and how they soared in communities that
were flooded with pain pills
and we saw the highest per capita death
rates nationwide were in rural west
virginia kentucky and virginia
and we could see that just six companies
distributed 76
of the pills during this period
and we could drill down into individual
drug companies
and pharmacy companies like walgreens
where we noticed that
at the height of the crisis all greens
sold about nearly one out of five of the
most addictive opioids
and that they had a really really
interesting company structure
they not only had
a franchise of pharmacies out there they
also
own the distribution company as well so
it was very much vertical integration
all the way
so while a lot of mom and pop pharmacies
could
argue that they didn't really know
exactly the impact
of all the in the search and orders for
opioids
in their pharmacy walgreens knew exactly
how much
and where these pills were going
and so we went through the effort of
geocoding 200 000 or so
pharmacies so that we could put on a map
and then really analyze geogra
geographic patterns that way
and we made an interactive that allowed
people to search their local
pharmacy and see the scale of sales
they did compared to their neighbors
and so we could really drill down an
individual pharmacies like this one
in florida this is a walgreens in
florida
and what's important to really note is
that it was the law for these companies
to
implement an effective system for
monitoring their opioid sales for
suspicious orders
and so we found so many pharmacies that
violated those suspicious orders
but kept selling anyway this is an
example of a store in oviedo florida
where starting in 2011 sales started
spiking
you can see it's declined a little bit
after legislators passed a bill to
limit the sales for a specific type of
oxycodone
and which slowed it for a month
until customers realized they could
order a different type of milligram
strength
and get that much easier and so that
started spiking even more
exponentially it got so bad that a
police chief in that town
make so many arrests that he wrote a
message to walgreens executives begging
them to change
their policies and to restrict it more
and to not sell the people who had been
previously arrested for selling
opioids on the street and to stop
selling to people who have been
rejected from other pharmacies with the
same prescription
but you can see it stopped for maybe a
month or slowed down for about a month
until it started
growing in sales once again and it
wasn't until around 2012 that sales
finally stopped
slowing started slowing down
but that was when they started realizing
that the dea was investigating several
stores as well as distribution center
until eventually that store was
suspended
and then
the distribution center itself in
florida that also got suspended
you can see here that it sent billions
of pills a month
to walgreens stores across the southeast
and florida
but you can see here thanks to the data
that even though they had been halted
starting in 2012 that another
distribution center
stepped up to fill those orders that
this particular
distribution center stopped handling so
walgreens
barely slowed down their sales
what was interesting about this data set
in the story that we did was that we
made the data
widely available to the public and we
put out explicit instructions on how to
use the data as well
because the thing is the data set was so
huge
that there were more stories that we
could possibly tell by ourselves
and the data could be applied to
specific communities
to see to see what they thought was more
interesting
and applied to them
and so on the first main page where you
could get see the
results of the opioid sales across the
country there was a section where
folks could navigate and find their
state and their county
and see exactly how many pills were sold
there which were the top distributors
which were the top manufacturers which
were the top pharmacies
and and get the numbers for them and not
only that
get generated vis specific to their
county
and also the summarized tables as well
as the raw data itself if they wanted to
do more deeper analysis
on top of that we took that data and we
used plumber to create an api out of it
and what was great about plumber is that
with very little coding
it will self-generate some great
documentation behind this
data portal we also created an
rapper around it for more ease
for especially our users
and then a researcher out in maryland
saw this and reached out
and went and made a python package
around this as well
and on top of that we created a bunch of
vignettes
and walkthroughs so that folks could
see exactly how we did our work but also
figure out how to tell stories relevant
to their communities as well
and we included functionality in the
package
to slice out the data beyond what we had
done in our stories
ourselves such as being able to
look at individual drugs and the data
set
for our stories we folks focused on
oxycodone and hydrocodone
but there are 12 other drugs in this
data set from marcos
that we didn't even look at the map on
the right
visualizes all the methadone sales
in boston it's this area called
methadone mile
and we made sure a bunch of functions
include a bunch of functions that
that we anticipated people would be find
useful such as bringing in the latino
longitude for all the pharmacies that we
looked up
we brought in population tables for
state county
and all the years the data was available
so that folks could normalize it well
and also all the summarized tables
because
it was important to make data accessible
it wasn't just enough to put a data set
on github
or put a link out there and then let
people
go through it themselves and figure out
how to do it deal with it
uh which you know researchers are great
at doing they can
they can create so many great research
projects around it such as the
effects of the opioid epidemic on the
housing market for example
but we went through the effort of
allowing many doorways to this data
through the api through the browser
itself on that main page
so that anyone with any level of
with different levels of expertise could
access this data
and sometimes it can convert
others to r which i find
is a success so
after we put all that data out there we
found out that within a few days
hundreds of stories were written by
local
by local journalists and it was amazing
for example the cleveland plains dealer
looked at the data and found
that there was one particular small town
doctor that was responsible for
selling 1.6 million pills which helped
fuel the surge there in ohio
radio station wosu looked at the data
and decided to focus
on the victims and telling their stories
as all the stories of those who were
left behind
the daily union in wisconsin looked at
the data
and tracked down the businesses who were
selling the most
pills and then went to see how much they
had donated
to politicians and to whom
the philadelphia enquirer made some
great interactive
visualizations that showed how after
oxycontin was
reformulated so that it was not as
crushable and snortable
that the demand for a different type of
oxycodone
surged instead
and through the data we're able to look
at manufacturers and manufacturers in a
new way
so while purdue got all the attention
based on the data we could see that they
only controlled about three percent
of the opioid market and that
three lesser-known generic drug
manufacturers actually manufactured most
of the addictive pills
however since they weren't well known
they avoided dea scrutiny for many
years
journalists also saw through the data
that lawmakers
were involved in this one lawmaker in
louisiana
a house member owned two pharmacies
that were 12.5 miles apart from each
other in a town that served 6 000 people
but sold 1.5 million pills
in that time period another legislator
that journalists found in the data set
was a state representative in tennessee
who was president and ceo of the largest
orders of opioids in the state
and what journalists connected with that
was that
earlier in the year this particular
state lawmaker shane reeves
actually introduced and helped pass a
law that made it
easier to access opioid prescriptions
and so as a result of all this four
companies that made or distributed
prescription opioids
and played roles in the catastrophic
opioid crisis have reached a tentative
26 billion dollar settlement with
country counties and cities that sued
them for damages in the largest federal
court case in american history
and internal documents out of all this
show that the pressure within the drug
companies to sell opioids
we're in conflict with numerous red
flags from the dea and even internal
workers
but the profits are huge that sales
didn't slow down
i'm still feeling the effects to this
day
in a different way prescription pain
pills were the main cause of overdose
death through 2011.
but then after laws were passed after
pharmacies pharmacists caught on after
doctors caught on and started
restricting access to
prescription pain pills drug users then
turned to heroin
which set the stage for venting and
together oxycodone hydrocodone heroin
and fentanyl have killed more than four
hundred thousand americans since the
turn of the century
a quarter of whom have died from
fentanyl in just the last six years
so i'm not exactly sure how to wrap up
this talk
but i want to point out that i hope the
data
that should have been kept an eye on by
pharmaceutical companies
by the government and has finally made
it into the hands of
the public to the researchers and
journalists out there i hope
we're able to hold everyone more
accountable so that we could prevent
more foster care children
anyway that's my talk
thanks so much for listening
you